Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Matt Reeves revealed that his version of
the Joker will not be in the Batman 2.
Any setting up a very different type
of trilogy for his Robert Pattinson
Batman universe
with all the spin off HBO series.
But the Joker will come back.
there's also a bunch of other stuff
that we've learned recently
about what's going on
with the next couple of Batman movies.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
from his inception, from his birth
life, has been a cruel joke on him.
And this is his response.
And he's eventually going to become
declare himself
as a clown, declare himself as the Joker.
he's had to spend the life of people
looking at him in a certain way
and he knows how to get into your head.
Matt Reeves released
this deleted scene with Barry Coen's Joker
after the first movie was released.
In the theatrical cut,
he barely had any kind of scene, like
just a quick Arkham scene of him
giving the Riddler a pep talk, implying
they should team up.
leaning heavily into the more comic book
aspects of their personas, like Paul
Dano's Riddler had not yet become full
comic book Riddler in the first movie,
Joker had not yet become a full joker,
as you would normally think of them.
He was basically telling Riddler
that this was just the beginning for them,
and most people just assumed
that they meant that they'd come back
as bigger characters in the Batman 2.
then Matt Reeves releases
the full deleted scene with The Joker,
and you can kind of see why he deleted it.
The movie was already really long
and the scene didn't necessarily add
that much to further
the main plot of him learning about
what's going on with the Riddler.
on alcohol and so on. So I.
Why should I?
To me, maybe he's a fan of yours,
it really only served to set up
the Joker character.
And a lot of people have complained
for many, many years now
that comic book movies
have a lot of stuff.
Hijacking the main plot for characters
or plot points that only serve to set up
sequels and spinoffs.
So this joker scene
would have kind of felt like that.
Like,
oh, he's just in here to set up a joker
spin off
or the Joker being in the Batman 2.
So understandable
that Matt Reeves got rid of the
scene, knowing now that the Joker
was not supposed to be in the Batman 2.
It makes even more sense
If he put this scene in the movie,
everybody on the planet
would just expect Joker
to be in that next movie.
this is his actual audition
for the Joker scene.
It feels like a very different idea that
he had for what his Joker would be like.
doesn't that version of his Joker
feel way more like A Clockwork
Orange type of Joker?
Like it's a self-made costume that came
the bowler hat all inspired
by Clockwork Orange his actual performance
as the Joker.
In that final version,
the scene feels totally different.
You can let me know which joker
you prefer, like Clockwork Orange Joker,
who feels a little more over-the-top
in a comic book
kind of way in the more chaotic
energy joker with a muted voice.
Like he's almost whispering his dialog
to Batman. There.
he's kind of very much out of the Conrad
Veidt sort of mold.
And that idea of the silent
film of the man who laughs, he's
got this congenital disease.
He can never stop smiling.
wanted to create an iteration of him
that felt distinctive and new,
but went right back to the roots.
What if this is
something that he's been touched on
that he's been touched by from birth, it's
not something where he fell in a vat
of chemicals or it's not the Nolan thing
where he has these scars
and we don't know where they came from.
and that he has a kind of
congenital disease that refuses to let him
stop smiling.
And he's had this very dark reaction
to it.
right now,
the current rumor and it's starting
to seem a little more likely is that Matt
Reeves will totally swerve on the Joker
character as a main villain
in any of his Batman movies,
like he's not saving him
so that he can be the main
villain of the Batman three
or anything like that.
But he will bring Joker back
at some point in the universe.
Like we have all the HBO Spin Off series.
There's an Arkham
Asylum TV show. These working on.
He might show up during that.
I think Matt Reeves idea is that he wants
the Robert Pattinson Batman movies
to feel as different
as possible from Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy, from Zack Snyder's Justice
League movie universe with the Jared
Leto version of The Joker
and from Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movies.
That's how many jokers we've had recently.
James
Gunn also has his version of the Batman
and going to be his Justice League
version of the Batman.
They'll probably be a joker
in that universe in the DCU eventually.
add another one to the pile.
and between all those versions, there's
been so much focus on the Joker character
the last 15 years that Matt Reeves
is going to make his Batman movies
different by just making the Joker
a supporting character,
like part of a larger rogue's gallery
so that he's active in the universe,
causing all kinds of mayhem.
but most theories right now
in Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson
have definitely thrown some fire on this.
Gasoline is the Batman two
main villain will either be Mr.
Freeze for someone that they haven't done
in any of the live action movies before.
hoping for. Mr.
Freeze,
Matt Reeves talked about this a while ago,
So a lot of people at the time
thought that an implied that Mr.
Freeze would be the main
villain Matt Reeves just said
even the idea of something like Mr.
Freeze. Such a great story, right?
So a lot of people were like,
Wait a minute,
does that mean he's actually doing Mr.
Freeze in the sequel?
The monster who took you from me
will soon learn that revenge is a dish
best served cold and The other big news is
that Matt Reeves is supposed
to introduce Clay Baze during the movie,
but he's not going to be the main villain.
Most people think that he's
going to be a version
of the original Clayface,
the Golden Age version.
The character called Basil Carlo.
not the shapeshifting metahuman. Clayface.
Matthew Hagen.
That's who most people think of
when they think of Clayface.
the reason why everyone's expecting
the original Clayface is
just because he's more of a real world
down to earth, kind of Clayface.
And that's the whole vibe of the Matt
Reeves Batman universe.
so far, we haven't seen any actual
metahumans in the world of the Batman yet.
So everything's been tech based,
at least so far.
The Basil Carlo Clayface was based on real
life, Boris Karloff and Basil Rathbone.
Carlo was meant to be a B-list actor
driven, insane
when he hears that they're remaking
his classic horror film without him.
during that movie, he played the villain
who is called Clayface,
and he puts that costume back on again,
killing all the actors who are
in the remake in the order that they got
killed in the original movie.
then eventually Batman
and Robin are able to stop him.
Don't be surprised.
They update his origin story
just a little bit
because they changed the Riddler's
origin story,
But they don't have to update
Clayface is origin
that much to make it fit
within this current universe.
and when we get to the Batman three,
we might even get the Court of Owls
as the main overarching villains,
which they've done in the animated movies.
They did them on the Gotham TV show,
but they haven't been done
in any of the live action movies yet
in the cast.
We're hyping them up.
After the last Batman movie came out,
there were a lot of Easter eggs
and references to the Court of Owls
during the first movie.
That's why the actors
were talking about it, like, yes,
there was a lot of court of appeals
in there.
Thomas and Martha were leaders
of the Court of Owls in this timeline.
Like that one.
Oh, that's of
I was definitely kind of thinking
it's probably going to be in the sequel.
It definitely seems nice. Mommy,
I'm not sure.
Just guessing, I guess.
Keep saying
good thing it's not in this film.
Or is it?
Or is let me know in the comments.
Where do you want to see Matt Reeves Joker
come back in the Robert Pattinson
Batman universe, like the movies,
the HBO TV shows that he's doing.
He's only announced two of them so far,
but there could be more after that.
We'll see.
this idea of him
being very kind of incisive and brilliant
and being able to get into your mind
and having basically having
this kind of nihilistic point of view
that sort of like think
you're only care my own way.
So I think you.
Oh, I'm sure he's got her
to think they deserved.
Yeah. Do you think it is everything?
in Who do you want to be
the main villain of the Batman three?
If it's going to be somebody
that they haven't used in the live action
Batman movies before
Most of you probably seen some Robin
talk in your feeds recently.
I know everyone's been fan casting.
Timothee Chalamet is a version of Robin.
He did talk about being Robin a while ago.
after seeing him in Dune, he could
actually do a pretty bad as Robin.
But the thing is, though, the report
is that during the Batman to Matt Reeves
is going to introduce a version
of Dick Grayson who is only 13 years old.
Zack Snyder did introduce a version
of Robin during Batman versus Superman.
But it was Dick Grayson, and he was killed
before the events of the movie.
that was meant to be this untold history
that he had with Joker and Harley Quinn
that they kind of alluded
to during the first Suicide Squad movie
and then later during the Justice
League, Snyder cut with their post-credits
scene where he was taunting Batman
in that post-apocalyptic future.
So this new
version of Robin that we're going to see
will be the first living version
that we've seen in the movies since Batman
and Robin with Chris O'Donnell's
Robin in George Clooney's Batman,
who we also just saw
at the end of the Flash movie
Right now, the Batman
two is supposed to come out in 2025.
It might get pushed to a little bit later
in the year with the recent delays,
but I'll do more videos for it
when we get more details about the story.
It's a long ways off.
And James
Gunn won't announce his Batman in Batman
braving the bolt until after the Batman
two comes out with Robert Pattinson.
They don't want to steal
any of their thunder,
so it'll be a while before we will learn
about that other version of Batman.
As far as I know, Andy Muschietti is still
directing Batman and Brave in the Bold,
even though everything is paused
by the strikes right now.
You know, there are a lot of complaints
about the Flash movie just in general.
one of the best aspects of that movie
was the way he treated
both versions of Batman in their action
on screen, like he actually did.
Really did
a good job of Ben Affleck's Batman
in a good job of Michael Keaton's Batman.
So even if a lot of people
were disappointed
by the actual flash of it
all in the overarching story,
the Batman stuff,
and it was actually pretty solid.
Ben Affleck
even said after he did his scenes
that he actually wanted
to come back a little bit,
even though he had told them
that he was done as Batman at the time
that Batman Penguin HBO series
was delayed a little so it should release
late 2024 or early 2025 before the Batman
two comes out in theaters.
But I'll do another trailer video for that
when we have some more footage.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Asoka Episode six video
we'll post later this week,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Click here to learn more about Robin
in the upcoming Matt Reeves
Batman movies and click here for my Ahsoka
Episode 6 Video.
Update the link as soon as I post that.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!